We are partners in TouchTen
My brother and I have been playing games since we were young
And when we founded a company
It was natural to work in the field we love
It is a games on mobile
Mobile games have become a global market for competition
But in the domestic market
Supports players in Indonesia
South-East Asia local content
We are locals and this is our strength point
We speak the same language and we have one culture
Our games include many common factors, such as food
We were based on the idea of ​​food
Warung Chain Game Maker
We learned from the statistics that many food lovers
They love opening their own restaurant
They provide them with our simulation game for it
Where players can own and manage a restaurant
Warung Chain has downloaded nearly 3 million users so far
Google Play has allowed us
Launch our games very easily
And give them to the players to be admired
Then get information to improve the game
In one of our games, Desert Chain
We tested two different versions
We found that more than 60% of local users
They prefer icon characters to symbol dishes
These comments were great for us
We were very proud to be involved with Warung Chain
In the first local game competition organized by Google in Indonesia
Our happiness was overwhelming
When we learned that Warung Chain is the winner
Indonesia has many enthusiastic developers
And a large proportion of the young population
Therefore, the domestic market can not be ignored
As we try to understand the local audience
We also seek to understand the global audience and provide valuable and useful content for them
This is in line with the name of our company, Touch Ten
Which means reaching the sky
This is our goal
We are proud that our game was made in Indonesia
We would like to highlight the Indonesian market
As a site for the gaming industry, not just for consumption